en el último vídeo definimos una
variable aleatoria x como el número de
soles que obtenemos en 5 volados y
después encontramos la probabilidad de
que nuestra variable aleatoria tomara
los valores 0 1 2 3 4 o 5 y para
visualizarlas lo que vamos a hacer es
graficar las y además así vamos a
obtener una visualización de cómo se
distribuye la probabilidad de esta
variable aleatoria aunque vamos a ver
una gráfica de su función de
probabilidad bueno entonces vamos a
graficar estas probabilidades por aquí
para poder seguir viendo estas
probabilidades vamos a tener en el eje
de las x todos los posibles resultados
los posibles valores que puede tomar x y
en el eje de las series vamos a obtener
con qué probabilidad x toma cada uno de
estos valores bueno entonces veamos las
probabilidades
tenemos por aquí puros treintaidosavos y
la probabilidad más alta es 10 32avos
entonces vamos a decir que por aquí
están los 10 32avos y el 1 está mucho
más arriba pero bueno después la mitad
más o menos por aquí tenemos la mitad
que son 5 treintaidosavos 5 32avos y si
dividimos este pedazo en cinco pedazos
iguales más o menos así por aquí este es
el 132 sabor aunque entonces tenemos por
aquí las probabilidades y por aquí vamos
a poner los posibles resultados
ok x puede ser igual a 0 entonces
ponemos por aquí x igual a cero este es
uno de los posibles resultados de
nuestro experimento y bueno lo que voy a
hacer es tal cual un mixto grama
entonces x igual a 0 cuál es
la probabilidad de que sea igual a 0 es
un 32avos tenemos por aquí
un 32 hago un 32 sabor y ahora vamos a
graficar la probabilidad de que x sea
igual a 1 eso es 5 32avos entonces
tenemos por aquí
aunque hay 5 32avos
esta es la probabilidad de que x sea
igual a 1
gray x igual a 1 todo este rectángulo
representa la probabilidad de que la
variable x sea igual a 1 y eso pasa si
en nuestro experimento de los cinco
lados sale exactamente un sol que es
esta probabilidad de aquí que es 5
32avos y bueno para dejar las cosas un
poco más uniformemente debía haber
dibujado esta barra del histograma de
este color entonces vamos a rellenarla
y ahora vamos a dibujar la probabilidad
de que de que sea igual a 2
esos son 10 32avos y se va a ver más o
menos así 10 32avos y bueno está padre
que lo estoy haciendo así porque me
gusta mucho más cómo se ven las cosas
dibujadas a mano que por ejemplo si
usted a la computadora para graficar
estas probabilidades
no sé cómo que las gráficas por
computadora suelen perder un poco de
personalidad
aquí tenemos 10 32avos
esta es la probabilidad de que la
variable x sea igual a dos aunque x
igualados o sea de que nos salgan dos
soles en los cinco volados que echamos y
luego tenemos la probabilidad de que x
sea igual a 3 que es 10 32avos o sea
hasta acá otra vez
ok 10 32avos
10 32 sabor
encuentro esto extrañamente terapéutico
en fin esta es la probabilidad de que la
variable x tomó el valor 3 aunque hay la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 3 y
ahora vamos con la probabilidad de que x
sea igual a 4 que es otra vez 5 32avos 5
32avos si es que su barra en el
histograma está por aquí
este rectángulo representa la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 4
x igual a 4 y ahora vamos con la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 5 x
igual a 5 tiene una probabilidad de 132
a bo o sea por aquí
x igual a 5
y ya que tenemos dibujada la función de
probabilidad podemos darnos cuenta de
dos cosas acerca de esta variable
aleatoria es una variable discreta y
finita ok finita porque solo puede tomar
seis valores solo puede ser igual a 0 1
a 2 a 3 a 4 oa 5 entonces es una
variable finita y además es una variable
discreta aunque bueno todas las
variables finitas son discretas pero si
puedes tener variables discretas que no
sean finitas por ejemplo si aquí
siguiéramos contando y x pudiera ser
igual a 67 y así siguiéramos sumando
números hasta infinito podríamos tener
una variable discreta e infinita para
ser discreta lo único que necesitas es
que después de un número sepas cuál es
el siguiente número y la variable no
pueda tomar ni un solo valor en medio de
esos dos valores entonces como podemos
ver x también es discreta y si nos
fijamos en la forma de las gráficas
probabilidades podemos ver que empieza
en un 32 sabor y luego va subiendo y
subiendo llega al punto máximo y después
empieza a bajar y bueno esta
distribución se llama distribución
binomial dis
binomial vino
miel
y bueno esta parte del nombre binomial
porque se llama distribución binomial
resulta que estas probabilidades si te
acuerdas del vídeo pasado las obtuvimos
utilizando combinatoria utilizando los
coeficientes binomial es que porque
estas cosas se llaman coeficientes
binomial es pues tenemos allí otro vídeo
acerca de los coeficientes binomial es
donde explicamos con todo detalle por
qué estos coeficientes se llaman
coeficientes binomial es pero tienen
mucho que ver con tomar un binomio y
elevarlo a alguna potencia entonces por
eso esta distribución se llama
distribución binomial por los
coeficientes binomial es y es una de las
distribuciones más importantes sobre
todo en estadística donde muchísimas
cosas que son discretas uno puede
suponer que se modelan muy bien con una
distribución binomial aunque hay que se
comportan como una distribución binomial
pero bueno en la serie de estadística
a ver con mucho detalle ahora si en
lugar de tener únicamente estos seis
casos tuviéramos por ejemplo no sé cinco
millones de casos o sea si en lugar de
tirar cinco volados tiraremos cinco
millones de volados como te puedes
imaginar estas barras se vuelven cada
vez más flacas y chaparras pero resulta
que la forma de la gráfica esta forma de
montaña no se modifica si disminuye su
altura pero se mantiene una forma muy
parecida a ésta y esa forma es una curva
que se llama la campana de gauss
entonces si tuviéramos más y más volados
más y más casos estas posibilidades se
van aproximando cada vez más a una
campana de gauss y seguramente has
escuchado acerca de la campana de gauss
pero bueno además esta campana de gauss
es la forma de la gráfica de la función
de densidad de la variable aleatoria
normal
una forma de pensar en la distribución
normal es pensar en la distribución cuya
función de densidad de probabilidad es
justo está campana de gauss esta curva
de amarillo ok y es una distribución
continua aunque bueno la distribución
normal se extiende mucho hacia la
derecha y hacia la izquierda y la
relación entre la distribución binomial
y la distribución normal en estadística
es que cuando tienes distribuciones
binomial es con un número de casos muy
muy muy grande por ejemplo cuando estás
pensando en moléculas o cuando estás
considerando cómo interactúan los
humanos pues son muchísimos los casos y
entonces y esto es algo muy común en
estadística la distribución normal
aproxima muy bien a esa distribución
binomial que tiene tantos casos y esta
aproximación es súper importante para la
ciencia y la estadística ok la binomial
es la distribución discreta y la normal
es la distribución continua
y es una muy buena aproximación entre
más casos tenga la binomial la
distribución normal es una mejor
aproximación de la distribución original
y muchas veces la normal es tan buena
aproximación que nosotros no podríamos
notar la diferencia ahora en estadística
es lo más natural modelar algunas cosas
con una distribución normal y se hace a
cada rato y funciona muy bien la mayoría
de los casos pero hay que tener mucho
cuidado porque en algunas ocasiones no
se puede modelar con la distribución
normal ok por qué puede hacer que el
proceso que nosotros queremos modelar
tiene lo que se llaman con las pesadas
que es que la probabilidad de que algo
suceda en estos extremos que la
distribución normal nos dice que es muy
improbable tiene una mayor probabilidad
que lo que nos dice la normal porque hay
veces que no es tan improbable que uno
de los resultados tenga un valor
muy grande y cuando se utilizan
distribuciones normales para modelar
esos procesos obtenemos como
consecuencias crisis financieras o cosas
por el estilo pero bueno ya no me quiero
desviar más del tema el chiste es que
aquí tenemos las probabilidades las
grafica mos y esta es la gráfica de la
función de probabilidad de una variable
binomial ahora como dijimos hace unos
cuantos minutos si tuviéramos muchísimos
muchísimos más volados hiciéramos la
gráfica de su función de probabilidad
estas barras serían más flacas y
pequeñas y se parecerían cada vez más a
una campana de gauss que es la gráfica
de la función de densidad de
probabilidad de la distribución normal y
esto lo estoy nadamás diciendo no lo
estamos demostrando y bueno en casos
límite si en lugar de tener una cantidad
finita de volados tuviéramos una
cantidad infinita de volados aquí en
lugar de tener una función de
probabilidad tendríamos la función de
densidad de probabilidad de la variable
normal
tal cual la campana de gauss la
distribución continua normal